he was the star for the Shanghai Sharks
now he plays for the Phoenix Suns and
good to have Jimmer Fredette
back on the program how did this come
about that you leave China and you end
up as a Phoenix Sun yeah you know my my
agent started talking with teams you
know knowing that I wanted to try to
make one more run back in the NBA so we
started talking to teams you know kind
of midway through the season and and you
know trying to get a feel out for what
was going on and you know sort of the
season the Phoenix Suns seemed like they
were very very interested and and you
know we started to talk with them and
see what the deal was and you know
ultimately they said that they wanted to
sign me once the season was over
so as soon as the season was over in
Shanghai I got on the plane the next day
and then clear write to Phoenix and you
know now I'm here what was the reaction
in China when you decided to leave
because you were big deal averaging 36 a
game yeah I mean honestly the people in
Shanghai were were just grateful for the
time that I've been there and they said
you know they wanted me to go out and
try to succeed in the NBA you know and
um you know so I'm grateful for that the
fans are supportive you know they
obviously love the time that I was there
and I love my time that I was there but
they were definitely supportive and and
still continuing to follow me it seems
like are you done in China you never
know you know you never can say anything
else blue with your career you just know
don't know exactly you know what's going
to happen but right now you know I'm
obviously back in the league and you
know I plan to stay here for a while
so I hope to be able to do that that's
the plan but you never know you know
where the chips will fall but you know
so you can never say never but hopefully
I'll be playing here for a while what's
different about your game now as opposed
to the last time you were in the NBA
I've had a great opportunity in China to
really work on my game like off the ball
you know when I first came into the
league I was much more comfortable
playing you know point guard on the ball
just because that's kind of what I did
in high school and at BYU and then once
I got to the NBA they had me playing a
lot more off the ball and I
I wasn't quite as comfortable doing that
but you know in China I've had a lot of
on court time being able to play off the
ball catch and shoot coming off of
different screens moving without the
ball and I think I feel a lot more
comfortable you know doing that now and
just have matured as a person matured as
a player you know and just feel a lot
more confident about my game and where
it's at were close to the first time
pretty incredible ovation last night how
would you describe that as you come back
to Salt Lake City yeah and I mean it was
it was pretty amazing I mean the fans in
Utah have been so so great to me and to
my family all the way through all of my
years at BYU and then afterwards they
continue to support me and follow me
throughout my career so to be able to
come in for the Novation like that was
was definitely a special moment in my
career so I just appreciate that that
from them and you know I wish I could
have made a couple more shots farm would
you go one for ten last night yeah one
for ten not not a great shooting night
for me but I think I was I was a little
lamp and myself just a little bit too
long and trying to get the feel of it
but you know it was it was good to be
out there okay Devin Booker has 56 he
goes back into the game
he then has 59 and then Utah decides
they're gonna foul somebody else so he
doesn't get a chance at 60 what'd you
think of that yeah obviously you know it
seems are competitive they don't want
they don't want the guys to score you
know 60 points on them obviously book
had a an amazing game and you know I
feel like if you really wanted to get
that ball he probably could have you
know I mean but he wasn't he wasn't
sweating it too much you know I mean
he's such a great scorer and a great
player I'm sure that he's gonna have
several more nights like that throughout
his career so he wasn't you know was
interpret about it too much or anything
like that he was just you know focused
on you know the game and not really
worried about trying to get a 60 ball so
uh but it was it was funny to see sure
yeah I like how Utah got upset you know
that he they were gonna let him get to
60 but they let him get to 59 Jimmer
right exactly he got the 59 so but they
weren't gonna let him get in no way you
know I was looking back on your numbers
in 2011 that you had three straight
tournament games when you had at least
30 points
you joined a pretty good list there Glen
Rice Glenn Robinson Steph Curry Austin
Carr and you what do you remember most
about that tournament it was a lot of
fun I mean state tournament there's not
you know when you're in college
basketball there's nothing like it
the feel around it the media hype around
it playing and then be arenas that are
that are sold out you know that's
something that you really don't get to
do as a college kid so you just feel
like you're on a much bigger stage
because you really are and you know to
be able to go out there and be able to
perform and and make a sweet 16 with
with our team and our guys was something
that they'll never forget but you know
it was it was just a amazing experience
you know everybody around the country
we're definitely aware of BYU basketball
at that time and they wanted to watch us
and see what we're gonna do so you know
it was special I had so much fun doing
that and you know just have great
memories from that tournament but didn't
LeBron tweet you after one game I had I
had a lot of lot of people tweet me at
that point and it was funny because you
know Twitter was just starting to kind
of kind of get bigger and you know they
were in my senior year most of the seat
bison here I didn't even have a Twitter
account and then towards the end of the
year I was like I should probably get
one you know a lot of people are
starting to tweet me and the good for
you know my promotions and all that
different type of stuff so I was like
I'm gonna get one and what I did yeah I
started getting tweets from a ton of NBA
players LeBron and Kevin Durant Steve
Nash and different rappers and actors
and all these different things so it was
it was definitely a fun time and you had
the green light like you didn't get
yelled at for shooting too much back
then in college did you know definitely
not and I had I mean I had great
teammates I mean that was a big big part
of it I mean my teammates you know could
have easily been
you know mad at me or jealous that I was
shooting the ball you know more than
than anybody else but all of my
teammates were supportive of me they
they realized that you know us playing
basketball that way it gave us the best
chance to win and to have the support of
your teammates say hey yeah go do your
thing and you know we're here to you
know to back you up is was something
that you know doesn't happen a ton you
know an Amanda and you know so I
appreciate the support of the teammates
and they realized that that was the best
way that we needed to play well welcome
back good luck with whatever happens
here at the end of the regular season
and hopefully you know get a fair shake
to make the roster coming up next season
but good to talk to you again Jimmer
yeah thanks Dan thanks for having me on
appreciate it and it's Jimmer Fredette
Phoenix Suns guard for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]